ghin joining me now is the a fer mention
Texas Attorney General Ken Paxton Ken
it's great to see you you want this
salon owner out of jail but how you
gonna make that happen you know it's a
complicated question we're operating
under a different regime than we've ever
operated under before and that judge
he'll she was held in contempt so the
governor can't actually pardon that and
so it's really public pressure and
because an appeal we can't get an appeal
done in time because she's only gonna be
there seven days but she ought to be
released immediately we're hoping that
public pressure and shows like this can
can highlight the injustice that's
happening to this mother I mean these
are individuals who are trying to save
their lives I mean when you when you
talk about something you've devoted
years to building Attorney General
Paxson that is their lives I mean it's
it's a tied to everything that they
dreamed of everything that they work for
their blood sweat and tears and such in
a way I saw someone read to say online
if she's fighting for her life but for
that they're putting her in jail Laura
you couldn't have said it's any better I
had my own business and you have rent
payments you have all kinds of expenses
that you're incurring while you're not
making any money and this is a woman
that has expenses she has children and
here she is she can't operate and all
she's done she hasn't she hasn't sold
drugs
she hasn't hurt anybody she doesn't
killed anybody and yet they're releasing
prisoners in Dallas and they're putting
her in jail now in Dallas County where
she was sentenced they've released about
a thousand inmates Harris County has led
over 370 walk free and one of those
inmates was arrested on charges of
possessing other people's IDs so ID
fraud and breaking into a car and then
another prisoner set free in Harris
County is now charged with beating his
ex-girlfriend throwing her grandmother
to the ground so how is it that these
people are being set free well people
just want to put food on the table run
their businesses responsible you're
being locked up is crazy [ __ ] I can't
believe this is America sometimes and I
can't believe this is Texas no and
it feels more like China in America and
let alone happening in Texas this is
exactly what you said we've got we've
got Rahm Emmanuel's statement from the
Clinton administration don't let a good
crisis go to waste that's certainly
happening here
where they're releasing potentially
thousands of convicted felons because
they're worried about them getting this
virus and for some reason they're not
worried about her a woman that's just
trying to do her job well I have to say
that I've been listening to a lot of the
elites criticisms of both Texas and
Florida it's the red states that they're
hitting hardest here despite the fact
that Texas has a relatively few Cova
deaths every death it's horrible we
don't anyone to die of it but compared
to New York or New Jersey the per
hundred thousand per million is a
fraction Florida has also had an
exemplary record but they're just
slashing it Texas like you guys are out
there just killing people because you
want to you know go to a bar barbecue or
something it makes no sense at all we've
literally tried to do our best at
balancing public health and saving lives
but allowing people some semblance of
their lives allowing them to make a lick
how is that wrong I just I literally
don't get it Attorney General Paxton
we're gonna be following this closely
thank you for what you're trying to do
and give voice to this at the very least